hey guys it's angelica the editor and
today i'm going to be checking out the
galaxy z flip 4 for the first time i
have not used a samsung phone ever and i
think the last time that i used a
android phone was six years ago i
currently use the iphone 13 pro and
today i'm going to be comparing
everything between these from the
displays designs speakers cameras
performance everything so let's go ahead
and unbox this thing wow
this looks so
different
than my iphone i was really bummed out
last year because
we did not get the z flip we only got
the fold ah that's so nice that's really
cool i was really really intrigued by
this phone this color this looks like a
banana we got we got gold and yellow
yellow here so starting with the design
obviously you can see we have a like hot
dog shape going on here um it seems like
the thickness is about the same if not
just barely barely thicker than the
iphone so holding it in the hand the
quality is like
amazing of course i didn't try the last
one so i don't know like you know what
to compare it to but this feels really
really really nice and sturdy the volume
buttons are on the top which is really
weird but what's cool is that when you
close it the volume button's inverse so
now this is up and down but when it's
closed it gets really really thick the
thickness of two phones obviously and
any ladies out there you know the
struggle of getting anything to fit in
your pocket so i wonder how these how
this is gonna fit that is
really really thick these pockets are
pretty big i don't know how this is
gonna work in like jeans at all it's
super thick
but it is really like small and compact
instead of
you know super long how was
that would not work out that would fall
out immediately so looking at these
camera bumps the iphone camera bump is
massive the samsung only has two cameras
this whole like area is really small but
it does have a display portion at the
top wow it has a lot of warnings
about the display and the hinge alright
so this hinge it's actually not as
noticeable as i thought it would be only
like when the light hits it you can kind
of see it but
feeling wise it's it's it's barely there
i can
barely feel it this is actually really
nice so before we check out the displays
let's listen to the speakers
[Music]
okay well the speakers on the the galaxy
on the flip are actually really really
good they sound
almost identical to the iphones i think
the highs and the bass is a little more
prominent on the flip than on the iphone
both are amazing i don't think you're
gonna go wrong now let's get into
displays and this brightness difference
is absolutely massive even the full
brightness for the iphone outside
sometimes i wish i could get brighter i
can't imagine what this is like to use
in full sun so i guess in the settings
there is an extra brightness toggle
which
i don't know why that isn't on by
default but now the displays are
actually almost identical they both have
a 120 hertz refresh rate which is great
because that's one of my all-time
favorite features about my iphone and it
enables 120 fps gaming if that's
something that you care about so now
let's get into hdr quality
looking at them right now
i am in shock of how much better
the flips display is than the iphones
everything about it the details the
contrast the colors look at how bright
that waterfall is both of these
apparently go up to 1200 nits and hdr i
i don't even understand how that's
possible because the flip is so much
brighter
so much better
and looking at these
these gaps
on the side like the bezel is definitely
a lot thicker and you can
zoom in but honestly who does that who
zooms into full screen mode and cuts off
stuff from the sides i know i don't i'm
pretty sure max and vadim don't either
but if you're somebody that does
this looks so much better without that
notch just with that hole punch cut out
i am so sick of this notch i'm ready for
it to go i am completely in shock by how
amazing the display on the flip is so a
cool feature about this flip is that
display
on the cover
so if i turn it on there is the time
with the battery and if i double tap i
can
swipe through widgets which is really
really cool and then if you
double press the fingerprint sensor then
the selfie camera
turns on if you press on the display
cool so now let's check out the
performance
the iphone 13 pro has the a15 ship while
the z flip 4 has the snapdragon 8 plus
gen 1
so
let's go ahead and run okay and the
results
are in and the
iphone is 20 faster in multi-core and 28
faster in
single core i'm surprised i thought it
would be closer this is the newest
snapdragon ship wow okay so the iphone
is gonna be quite snappier but let's
test out the graphics because that is
the
major benefit of the new snapdragon chip
we're gonna use a gfx benches 4k aztec
ruins high tier off screen so let's
start okay and this is interesting
the iphone actually won by 1 fps we have
20 fps over here and
20.9 fps
on the iphone i was expecting it
to beat it out
i guess not so the performance should be
similar but i wonder
how the experience is
gaming on this really wide
phone
maybe i'll have to test it one day now
talking about the cameras as you can see
the iphone's lenses are
way bigger
than the flips both of these are 12
megapixel
and then the display one is 10 and the
iphone has an extra telephoto lens which
means that the zoom shots are going to
be a lot better
but we are actually going to do a blind
camera comparison with this the iphone
and what else
the pixel
and the pixel so if you want to watch
that that's going to come out very soon
so i am actually going to be switching
and using this phone for a week ditching
my iphone um i'm really excited i'm very
very impressed with this the main thing
that you want from a phone like this is
for it to be
exactly like a normal phone
just with the flip aspect added to it
and
the speakers
were amazing the display was insanely
amazing the performance is really good
so i'm really impressed i'm really
excited to use this for a week and let
you guys know what i think
so thank you for watching click the
circle above to subscribe and go ahead
and watch one of those two videos over
there this has been angelica with max
tech and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
you